Michelle is with us in Lexington hi
Michelle how are you hi how are you
today better than I deserve what's up I
have a 16 year old will have four
children but my Otis is 16
of course her driver's license was
coming around this year and the goal a
year ago was if you have five hundred to
a thousand dollars saved we will match
it to help you get a car we've sat down
and did in the budget now we're still
new to everything because we've only
done your class about two years ago so
we're still my husband and I are still
paying off a lot of debt and raising
four children my question is my daughter
we opened her a checking account a
savings account last year when we
started this goal she is a little bit of
an entrepreneur she does her own little
sewing sales a little bit on the side
and she's a little gardener old she
raised a garden an acre sold to the
neighbors and up and down the road made
over twelve hundred dollars in one month
last year plus she maybe said good for
her
well good for her but she doesn't know
how to handle that money and as much as
I have tried to sit down and budget with
her a little bit of it probably is just
my fault
maybe not keeping up with it all of the
month of July with her my work had
really kicked in we're really budgeting
so I feel like I failed her a little bit
but however I felt like we had done the
envelope sent down in budget and we had
talked she still blew through over $700
in July and I said him and talked with
her and she was really aggravated so how
much does she have in savings now $500
okay and that's all she has and she
hasn't only because he shut down her
checking account we closed it and she
cannot get anything out the same of
course I'm with her on it but we both
have to find for her to get anything out
well you're gonna have to put it back
open and you're gonna have to manage it
with her because she has to learn this
skill otherwise she'll be 50 years old
and still acting like she's acting now I
know and that's my question as a mother
right now
she
her driver's license next month I'm
shooting him she's got 500 bucks you
said you'd match it it's 500 bucks 500
bucks will match it so we should go
ahead a match even though she doesn't
have enough money for her insurance well
thank you guys I think you've worked
through that she's gonna get a hoopty
and you've learned a lesson that you
have to manage 16 year olds you can't
let him run wild and she's learned a
lesson that if she spends everything she
makes she act the only job you can do
that in this Congress yes well that was
my question I didn't I didn't know if I
was going to be too hard you didn't
change the rules okay honey are the
rules didn't she yeah that's not harsh
life life will teach you some stuff it's
called natural consequences of stupid we
all get them this is the Dave Ramsey
show
you